[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend das
Gesetzesentwürfe verändert werden sobald
sie durch die Ausschüsse des Bundestags
gehen ist normal in Berlin zitiert man
da gerne das strucksche Gesetz benannt
nach dem Verstorbenen SPD-Politiker
Peter Struck der ist seinerzeit auf den
Punkt brachte kein Gesetz komme aus dem
Parlament so heraus wie es eingebracht
worden sein soweit so normal aber das
Regierungsmitglieder zuerst am
Kabinettstisch die Hand heben und einem
Entwurf zustimmen und dann zugleich eine
Art minderheitsvotum abgeben und
schriftlich erklären man hoffe auf
Änderungen das erscheint nicht ganz so
normal so geschehen heute beim Gebäude
Energiegesetz Stichwort
heizungsaustausch das Brot Weg berichtet
der Streit vorbei die Weichen gestellt
das Heizen in Zukunft planbar trotz
ungewisse Umstände das in etwa dürften
sich diese beiden als politisches Signal
heute vorgestellt haben
vor allem bin ich sehr zufrieden und
das darf ich vielleicht zu offen sagen
hätte dass mit dem Verlauf der Leute
auch nicht immer für möglich gehalten
dass wir jetzt in diesem Frühjahr das
Gesetz verabschieden und damit eine
Chance haben das auch noch vor den
Sommerferien durch die beiden
gesetzgebungskammern zu bringen und das
halte ich auch für erstrebenswert eine
Pflicht um sofortigen Austausch
bestehende Heizungen soll nicht kommen
durchaus aber bestimmt der Fristen dafür
übernimmt der Staat bei neuen
klimafreundlichen Heizungen als
Grundförderung 30% der Kosten und bei
früherem Austausch als Klima Bonus
weitere 20 wer lieber wartet dann aber
eine Heizung installierte die Vorgaben
über erfüllt soll noch 10% Bonus
erhalten ebenso Havarie Fälle wenn etwa
eine noch zulässige Heizung vorzeitig
den Geist aufgibt neue Kohle und
Ölheizungen werden nicht gefördert so
ziemlich alles andere aber schon
sie kriegen die 30 Prozent egal welche
Heizungstechnik sie sich auswählen sie
kriegen den Bonus 1 und 2 auch egal
welche Technik Sie auswählen und Sie
können dann selber entscheiden ob sie
eine Wärmepumpe haben wollen solartermin
einen Wasserstoff Heizung oder aber eine
Holzpelletheizung trotzdem der Streit
geht weiter auch im Kabinett kaum hat
der Finanzminister hier dem
Gesetzentwurf zugestimmt jagte eine
Protokoll Notiz hinterher das Parlament
werden notwendige Änderungen vornehmen
Bedenken zu Finanzierbarkeit und
Umsetzbarkeit müssten beachtet
Befreiungen etwas für
Sozialhilfeempfänger oder über
80-jährige Betroffene verfassungskonform
und sachgerecht gestaltet werden
der ursprüngliche Gesetzentwurf von
Robert Habeck war gut gemeint aber er
war eben nicht gut gemacht wir wollen
dafür sorgen dass dieses Gesetz gut
gemacht ist
Änderungsbedarf hatte dann hätte er
etwas ändern können im Kabinett die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger warten von uns
auch zu Recht dass wir das nach vorne
stellen was gutes Land ist und nicht nur
das was gut für die Stimmung auf ein
paar Tagen ist eine Steilvorlage für die
Opposition das Gesetz so wie es heute im
Kabinett beschlossen worden ist hat
schon in der Koalition keine Mehrheit
das ist ein bemerkenswerter Vorgang das
Chaos bei der wärmewende geht weiter in
der Koalition mit der Opposition
streiten werden sie weiter demnächst an
anderer Stelle
fragen wir einfach mal nach bei Theo
Koll ja also erst zustimmen und zugleich
auf Änderungen drängen ist das ein
ungewöhnlicher Vorgang das kann man so
sagen ja und das Lindner in seiner
Protokolle Erklärung schreibt der Stimme
nur zu im Bewusstsein dass der Bundestag
die notwendigen Änderungen vornimmt ist
ja eigentlich eine regelrechte
Aufforderung an die FDP-Fraktion der
eigenen Regierung in die Speichen zu
greifen übermorgen beginnt der Parteitag
der FDP der Parteichef musste da sicher
auch rechtzeitig eine Art Ventil
einbauen denn einzelne liberale
Abgeordnete die sprechen schon von einer
Atombombe für unser Land selbst führende
grüne wussten heute morgen noch nichts
von dieser regierungsinternen
Protestnote und meinten heute Abend
allerdings hinter den Kulissen sie seien
alle fassungslos sind jedem Fall macht
es deutlich in welchem Zustand die Ampel
gerade ist und wie hat gesotten das Maß
an Rempelei innerhalb der Regierung
momentan ist aber das jetzt Zeitungen
auf überwiegend erneuerbare Energien
umgerüstet werden sollen dass das stand
ja eigentlich schon im Koalitionsvertrag
also warum ist darum überhaupt noch mal
so ein Streit entbrannt absolut es steht
im Kapitel Klimaschutz im Gebäudebereich
allerdings ohne genauere Details und
sollte auch ja eigentlich erst ab 1
Januar 25 gelten dann hat die Koalition
gemeinsam auf 24 vorgezogen der
daraufhin dann im Ministerium
erarbeitete Gesetzentwurf zum
Heizungstausch der wurde in einer frühen
Fassung durchgestochen und geisterte
dann ja tagelang durch eine sehr
aufgeregte politische Debatte alles zu
Lasten von Robert Harbeck denn vieles
war ja noch unklar wer muss was umrüsten
zu welchen Kosten mit welchen
staatlichen Hilfen und das bei einem
Thema das ja eigentlich jeden im Land im
absolut privaten Bereich betrifft also
ein ziemlichespa Desaster für den
Wirtschaftsminister dann hat sich die
FDP auch noch bei efuels und dem letzten
Koalitionsausschuss mit einer
Verwässerung des klimaschutzgesetzes
durchgesetzt und spätestens dann war
klar dass die Grünen diesmal nicht
nachgeben werden mal sehen wie das
Gesetz nach der Beratung im Bundestag
dann aussieht danke schön
der Aufstand begann am 19 April
1943 obwohl sie kaum Waffen hatten
stempten sich die im Warschauer Ghetto
eingesperrten fast vier Wochen lang
gegen die Truppen der SS mit dem Mut der
Verzweiflung und dem Wissen dass die
Deutschen sie so oder so vernichten
wollten an diese Ereignisse vor 80
Jahren erinnerte heute Bundespräsident
Steinmeier als erstes deutsches
Staatsoberhaupt war er dazu eingeladen
zum Jahrestag am Ehrenmal in Warschau zu
sprechen das ist eine besondere Geste
der Polen gerade in Zeiten in denen das
deutsch-polnische Verhältnis eher
schwierig ist Natalie Steger berichtet
das war schon
zwei die das Schicksal verbindet
Christina budnitzka und Marian calvare
waren im Ghetto interniert sie waren
Kinder aber die Erinnerung ist nicht
verblasst
diese Kinder die krank oder verhungert
auf den Gehsteigen lagen
auf der Straße lagen viele Kinder
wollten obwohl ich nie etwas Schlechtes
getan habe warum meine einzige Sünde war
dass ich als Jüdin geboren wurde
am Mittag einen Moment des Innehaltens
in Warschau im Gedenken
[Musik]
am Ghetto Denkmal Bundespräsident
Steinmeier mit Polens Präsident duda und
Israels Präsident Herzog seit an seit
einst Knete Kanzler Willy Brandt hier
noch allein heute ein Zeichen der
Versöhnung etwas das sich die damals
ermordeten Juden nicht hätten vorstellen
können so Herzog
dass wir Präsidenten von Israel Polen
Deutschland hier 80 Jahre später stehen
ihr Heldentum würdigen und gemeinsam in
ihrem heiligen gedenken schwören nie
wieder
Steinmeier erinnert an die schwere
Schuld der Deutschen der ganzen Wahrheit
gehört allerdings auch
dass viel zu wenige andere Täter sich
verantworten mussten nach dem Krieg ich
stehe heute vor ihnen
und bitte um Vergebung für die
Verbrechen
die deutsche hier begonnen haben vom
Ghetto auswerten die Juden damals in
Vernichtungslager deportiert mit unter
Tausende an einem Tag weil sie wissen
dass sie nichts mehr zu verlieren haben
erheben sich jüdische Kämpfer vor 80
Jahren gegen ihre Peiniger nach vier
Wochen lassen die Nazis das Ghetto in
Flammen aufgehen es wird zum Massengrab
gedenken in der Synagoge Warschaus die
Deutschen haben das jüdische Leben in
der Stadt einst fast ausgelöscht sie
würdigen den Mut der Heldinnen und
Helden des Widerstands was häufig falsch
angenommen worden ist dass im
Nationalsozialismus Juden sich vilemma
haben zu Schlachtbank führen lassen und
hier wird ganz deutlich dass sie dazu
nicht bereit waren nie wieder ist die
Botschaft des Tages und der Auschwitz
Überlebende marientourski mit einer
Mahnung seit wachsam
darf ich gleichgültig sein darf ich
schweigen wenn heute die russische Armee
Aggression gegen die Nachbarn und die
Besatzung seines Territoriums ausübt
es ist seine Botschaft an die jetzt Zeit
von einem der weiß was Krieg Verfolgung
und Vernichtung bedeuten und von einem
der wenigen gebliebenen Zeitzeugen des
Holocausts
auch Bundespräsident Steinmeier Sprache
in seiner Rede den russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine an und
sagte dass Deutschland gemeinsam mit
Polen und anderen Bündnispartnern fest
an der Seite der Ukraine stehe mit dem
Thema beginnen jetzt die Nachrichten
Heinz der Deutschland hat der Ukraine
des Luftverteidigungssystem Patriot zur
Verfügung gestellt die Bundesregierung
gab die Lieferung auf ihrer
Internetseite bekannt Patriot zählt
aktuell zu den modernsten
Flugabwehrsysteme der Welt Deutschland
die USA und die Niederlande hatten sich
bereit erklärt der Ukraine jeweils eine
Einheit zu überlassen ukrainische
Soldaten wurden extra ausgebildet um das
System bedienen zu können
aufgrund des russischen Angriffs Krieges
gegen die Ukraine sehen deutsche
Sicherheitsbehörden die Bedrohungslage
im cyberraum weiterhin sehr angespannt
bei einer Konferenz zur cybersicherheit
in Potsdam sagt die BKA-Chef München
Angriffe im Zusammenhang mit Pro
russischen Akteuren hätten zugenommen
eine weitere Bedrohung für Wirtschaft
und Kommunen sehen die
Sicherheitsbehörden in Renz und wer
Angriffen bei denen Cyberkriminelle von
den Betroffenen Lösegeld fordern
ein Gericht in Moskau hat die Berufung
des kremlkritikers Ilja Yashin gegen
seine Verurteilung zu achteinhalb Jahren
Haft abgewiesen ja schön wird
Verbreitung von Falschinformationen über
die Streitkräfte vorgeworfen es geht
dabei um Veröffentlichungen zu den
Gräueltaten in der ukrainischen Stadt
Botschaft jasching geht als enger
vertrauterdes ebenfalls Inhaftierten
Oppositionsführers
das Europaparlament hat schärfere
importregeln zum Schutz des Regenwaldes
beschlossen demnach dürfen Unternehmen
Produkte wie Kaffee Holz oder Palmöl nur
noch in der EU verkaufen wenn eine
sorgfaltserklärung abgegeben wird dass
das Produkt nirgends zu einer Schädigung
des Waldes geführt hat die EU-Staaten
müssen noch zustimmen was aber als
Formsache gilt
bahnreisende sollten sich für Freitag
nach Alternativen umsehen wegen eines
bundesweiten Bahnstreiks der
Gewerkschaft EVG wird der Zugverkehr
erneut teilweise ausfallen Fernzüge
stehen zwischen drei und 13 Uhr still
bis abends soll es Einschränkungen geben
der Regionalverkehr fällt bis 11 Uhr
morgens weitgehend aus zudem hat die
Gewerkschaft Verdi für die kommenden
Tage zu Arbeitsniederlegungen an
Flughäfen aufgerufen betroffen
Düsseldorf Köln-Bonn Hamburg und
Stuttgart
sich weiter im Sudan aufzuhalten ist so
gefährlich geworden dass die Bundeswehr
die noch verbliebenen deutschen
Staatsbürger dort rausholen soll dabei
handelt es sich vor allem um
Botschaftspersonal und
Entwicklungshelfer an erster Versuch
dazu wurde heute aber abgebrochen
nachdem eine eigentlich vereinbarte
Feuerpause nicht eingehalten und der
Luftraum über der Hauptstadt cartoon
geschlossen ist es schien eine Landung
der deutschen Transportflieger als zu
riskant in dem nordostafrikanischen
Staat toben seit Tagen Kämpfe zwischen
zwei rivalisierenden militärgruppen und
ihren generellen die das Land bislang
gemeinsam geführt hatten Glückwunsch
berichtet
heftige Kämpfe auch heute wieder in
cartoon vor allem um das
Flughafengelände Menschen können nicht
in Sicherheit gebracht Hilfsgüter nicht
eingeflogen werden in den Straßen
unterdessen schwer bewaffnete Kämpfer
die Vereinten Nationen sprechen von
mindestens 270 Toten bislang und fast
3000 verletzten viele Krankenhäuser
wurden angegriffen in den wenigen die
noch in Betrieb sind fehlen Medikamente
Material Blutkonserven
auf den Straßen verwiesen die Leichen
sie zu bergen wäre für die Menschen
lebensgefährlich wer kann verlässt die
Kampfgebiete andere Menschen stehen
stundenlang an für ein Stück Brot es
gibt kaum noch Lebensmittel Wasser und
nur sporadisch-
das ist die einzige Bäckerei die noch
Brot liefert für sechs stattviertel die
einzige
bewaffnete ziehen plündern durch die
Straßen es gibt Berichte von gewaltsamen
Überfällen und sexueller Gewalt auch
un-helfer wurden angegriffen und das
solchen Umständen so der
un-sonderbeauftragte pertis in kartum
kann man keine Hilfe leisten
sie sind für diese Gewalt verantwortlich
Armeeführer abdelvater Heilbronn
Staatschef des Sudan und sein
Stellvertreter milizen-chef der
millionenschwere daglow ist für
zahlreiche Kriegsverbrechen im
Bürgerkrieg in davor verantwortlich sein
bisheriger Partner General bohrhahn war
die rechte Hand des gestürzten
sudanesischen Diktators und
Kriegsverbrechers albershire vor zwei
Jahren putschten albohan und sich noch
gemeinsam an die Macht diese Einigkeit
ist vorbei
jetzt geht es mit aller Gewalt um die
Alleinherrschaft und um viel korruptes
Geld aus Ölquellen und Goldmine im Land
und das in einem Staat in denen die
Hälfte der Bevölkerung auf
internationale Hilfe angewiesen ist
wir Bürger zahlen jetzt den Preis dafür
dass die Verbrechen der militionäre und
der Armee aufgearbeitet wurden auch das
ein Vermächtnis von Ex-Diktator
albertiert
seit heute abend gilt erneut eine sehr
brüchige Feuerpause tausende versuchten
heute schon mit Bussen und zu Fuß aus
den Kampfgebieten zu fliehen dass die
beiden Kriegsführer zu einer Lösung am
Verhandlungstisch bereit wären daran
glaubte im Sudan derzeit kaum jemand
der Sudan liegt leider nur einer von
vielen Weltregionen in denen Menschen
sich zu Recht fragen ob sie dort jemals
einigermaßen sicher und gute leben
können wer jede Hoffnung verliert
versucht zu fliehen die Probleme die mit
Flucht und Vertreibung einhergehen sind
bekannt und eines der großen Themen der
Weltpolitik ganz am Ende sind es dann
aber einzelne Gemeinden und Landräte die
diese Welten Läufe praktisch lösen
müssen und wo guter Wille allein nicht
ausreicht Thomasberg beschreibt das dann
Beispiel einer Gemeinde im Landkreis
es sollten nicht alle Platz finden
gestern Abend in Görlitz zur
öffentlichen Kreistags Sondersitzung wer
es in den Saal schaffte der erhoffte
sich vom Landrat antworten denn die
Flüchtlingszahlen sie wollen einfach
nicht sinken wo sollen die alle hin was
soll ich hier werden also das beängstigt
mich eigentlich ja
natürlich besetzt die AFD das Thema in
Görlitz prominent mit dem Bundessprecher
der auch im Görlitzer Kreistag sitzt wer
gestern schon verängstigt hier ankam der
sollte auch verängstigt nach Hause gehen
in diesem Landkreis
zu Schaden kommt
[Musik]
der nüchterne Hintergrund wie alle
Landkreise in Deutschland braucht auch
Görlitz dringend Gebäude für
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen hier in
Hirschfelder Rosenthal könnten 150
Menschen Platz finden in einem Ortsteil
mit 120 Einwohnern fast ohne
Infrastruktur geprägt von
Einfamilienhäusern mit oft älteren
manchmal auch allein lebenden Bewohnern
und Bewohnerinnen
200 Meter von der Unterkunft entfernt am
neißeufer führen engemanns einen
Tourismus und veranstaltungsbetrieb
wochenlang hatten Gerüchte die Runde
gemacht und genaues steht auch bis jetzt
nicht fest und gerade deshalb blicken
die engemanns mit Sorge auf die
Sommersaison wir wissen ja noch nicht
was auf uns zukommt wie viele
Flüchtlinge kommen welche Nationalitäten
das kommen wir haben Angst davor dass
wir viel Polizeiaufkommen an hier haben
werden die Leute die Gäste kommen zu um
uns um hier ihre Hochzeit zu feiern in
ihren Schuleintritt zu feiern die
Geburtstage zu feiern unbeschwert zu
sein die meisten in Görlitz Beklagten
wie sparsam und spät sie über die Pläne
informiert wurden der Landrat sieht hier
einen Dilemma
wie man es macht macht man es falsch
wenn man zu früh informiert und noch
nicht alle Fragen beantworten kann stößt
das auf Kritik wenn man aber dann zu
spät mit einer ersten Informationen
kommt dann ist es berechtigterweise auch
kritikfähig und von daher immer in so
einer Gemengelage die schwierig ist
demnächst soll einen Betreiber Konzept
für die Einrichtung vorliegen ein
kleiner Schritt aber in welche Richtung
die AFD zumindest fand für Ihren Antrag
der Landkreis möge die Aufnahme von
Flüchtlingen praktisch komplett
verweigern gestern bei anderen
Fraktionen keine Stimmen
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter mit dem Blick auf die deutsche
Wirtschaft da ist die Zahl der
Firmenpleiten erneut gestiegen schon von
Januar auf Februar gab es mehr
Insolvenzen und dann im März noch mal
mehr als im Februar hat der Statistische
Bundesamt bekannt gegeben Frank Bethmann
wie ist dieser Anstieg einzuordnen
schöne Entwicklung aber vom Verband der
Insolvenzverwalter kommt dazu ein
richtiger und vor allem wichtiger
Hinweis der Anstieg jetzt wenn man es
langfristig betrachtet bedeutet er eine
Normalisierung will sagen zuletzt gab es
historisch wenig Firmen Pleiten auch
weil das Insolvenzrecht teilweise
gelockert wurde und es während der
coronazeit kräftige staatliche Hilfen
gab nun aber zeichnet sich eine
Trendwende ab höhere Produktionskosten
wachsende Personalausgaben und nicht
zuletzt der deutlicher Anstieg der
Zinsen der die Kredite verteuert hat
können von immer mehr betrieben nicht
mehr gestemmt werden nach und nach geht
ihn nun also das Geld aus von einer
Pleitewelle wollen Fachleute zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt aber noch nicht
sprechen und welche Branchen sind
besonders betroffen das außer alte zum
Jahresanfang vor allem Unternehmen in
dem Baugewerbe was wenig wundert die
deutsche Bauwirtschaft steht vor
schweren Zeiten und auch im Handeln
müssen zunehmend Geschäfte schließen
Stichwort leer stehende Läden in den
bestätigen hier an der Börse heute
weniger Leerstand mehr Stillstand der
DAX kaum verändert bei am Ende
15.895 Punkten Frank Bethmann vielen
Dank
nach der kurzfristigen Verschiebung der
Abiturprüfungen in Nordrhein-Westfalen
hat sich Ministerpräsident wüst bei den
Betroffenen entschuldigt und eine
gründliche Untersuchung des Vorfalls
versprochen massive technische Probleme
hatten gestern dazu geführt dass
Lehrkräfte die Aufgaben für die heute
angesetzten Prüfungen nicht
herunterladen konnten die Verschiebung
auf Freitag löste Kritik aus unter
anderem wegen des muslimischen
zuckerfestes an diesem Tag
der bekannte DDR Sportreporter Heinz
Florian Oertel ist wie heute bekannt
wurde Ende März im Alter von 95 Jahren
verstorben
Urtel zählte zu den bekanntesten Stimmen
des DDR Rundfunks und berichtete unter
anderem von 17 Olympischen Spielen und
acht Fußball-Weltmeisterschaften
örtelstab im Kreis seine Familie in
Berlin
und jetzt zu den Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr drei 14 16 18 31 36 Superzahl 6
und weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
die gelegten Schätzung E-Mails von
Springer Vorstandschef Döpfner sorgten
ja für einiges Aufsehen nimmt man sie
wörtlich entsteht das Bild eines Mannes
der den Klimawandel angenehmen und die
FDP gut findet ansonsten aber von
anderen Sterblichen keine allzu hohe
Meinung hat wobei ein schwer zu sagen
wäre wen er am schlimmsten findet
intolerante Muslime Ossis oder Angela
Merkel
Journalisten kommen auch nicht gut weg
fast alle propaganda-assistenten
ausgenommen einige Hand verlesene
Edelfedern der Springerpresse die er
allerdings gelegentlich anregen musste
noch mehr für die FDP zu tun fast ist
man versucht zu sagen dem Konzern-Chef
noch mehr bei der Durchsetzung seiner
Agenda zu assistieren
erklärte Liebling war der später
geschafft des Chefredakteur Julian
Reichelt der sich mit döpfern inzwischen
aber eine Art Rosenkrieg liefert und vor
dieser Kulisse tritt jetzt noch ein
weiterer Spieler auf der für Spektakel
allemal gut ist Buchautor Benjamin von
Stuckrad-Barre eins auch einen Empfänger
persönlicher Döpfner Nachrichten sein
neuer Roman handelt von Macht und macht
Missbrauch in einem Medienhaus
ähnlichkeiten mit lebenden scheinen
unübersehbar und bezeichnend ist auch
der Titel noch wach
heute abend stellt er sein Buch in
Berlin vor in einem Theater natürlich
Claudio Armbruster hat schon vorher mit
ihm gesprochen
Benjamin von stuckrad Barre hat ein Buch
geschrieben das ist sein Job er ist
Schriftsteller doch dieses Buch wird
heiß erwartet denn es geht um Themen die
heiß diskutiert wurden in den
vergangenen Jahren und jetzt wieder
diskutiert werden dieser Tage
fangen wir mal ein Chef und eine
Volontärin
verlieben sich am Arbeitsplatz
ineinander wunderschöne Geschichte am
Faxgerät ging es los und heute haben sie
keine Metall aber ist es für beide
gleich leicht diese Beziehung zu beenden
Antwort ist klar
das da findet macht Missbrauch statt der
Mann wechselt dann vielleicht den
Arbeitgeber die Position oder so die
Frauen wechseln ihren Beruf die wechseln
die Stadt die wechseln ihr Leben danach
das Buch handelt von Macht eines
Menschen Fall als Fall der Menschheit
stuckrad barbara war eine Zeitlang der
Macht sehr nah er verdiente nicht nur
sein Geld beim Springer Verlag aber auch
befreundet mit Matthias Döpfner dem
Springer Chef
als 2021 macht Missbrauchsvorwürfe gegen
Julian Reichelt den damaligen
Chefredakteur der Bild-Zeitung laut
wurden gab es Kontakt zwischen den
Frauen die die Vorwürfe erhoben und
stuckrad Barbara
der Umgang mit dem realen Fall von dem
dieses Buch inspiriert ist aber nicht
handelt
seine fiktionale Geschichte aber
ich habe Beobachtungen Erfahrungen
gemacht und mir dann so meine Gedanken
und mir die eine dazu passende
Geschichte ausgedacht
noch wach erzählt viele Geschichten vom
bitteren Ende einer Freundschaft von me
too am Pool des Hotels in Hollywood und
von macht Missbrauch hinter
verspiegelten Fenstern in diesem Roman
geht es weniger um die Täter als um die
Betroffenen und es geht um die Mitwisser
um den Umgang mit den Mitwissen
das heißt dann wir haben gelernt da sind
Fehler passiert
alles in Ordnung jetzt und wir haben
daraus gelernt der Blick geht nach vorne
aber vielleicht wollen da Leute noch was
hören die darunter gelitten haben
und die leitender bis heute drunter
mindestens alle zwei Tage ruft mich
jemand an
sind Therapie geht den gar nicht mal so
gut in diesem Fall in dem ich
Sachen bezeugt habe und und
miterlebt habe
und diese Erlebnisse mit habe einfließen
lassen können in die Fiktion dieses
Romanes alle gehen da beschädigt und
zerstört raus
und das ist Wahrheit
ja wer will der kann diesen Roman als
Schlüsselroman lesen aber er ist vor
allem ein Sittengemälde nein ein
unsittengemälde unserer Zeit
das war's von uns ist folgt eine
Dokumentation mit dem schönen Titel Gras
dir großes Geld da geht es aber nicht um
Medienkonzerne sondern um online
Betrügereien und um 0:45 Uhr gibt es
dann unser heutigen Update mit nazanödem
und uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
guten Abend das hier sind die
Temperaturen etwa in anderthalb
Kilometern Höhe sie sehen hier diese
kaltluftblase das ist ein
Kaltlufttropfen über Deutschland der
zieht weiter in Richtung Frankreich und
biegt dann Richtung Nordseeküste ab es
gibt aber nicht nur interessante
Temperaturen sondern es gibt auch Wolken
Regen blau und Schnee rosa und sie sehen
hier wie dieser Kaltluft Tropfen morgen
bereits Frankreich erreicht hat heute
Nacht zieht er von Berlin bis nach Bonn
und in den Mittelgebirgen oberhalb von
400 bis 600 Meter hier weiß markiert
kann es sogar schneiden auch am
Alpenrand Feld Schnee am ehesten trocken
bleibt es so Richtung Saarland oder auch
an der Nordseeküste bei einem Wind aus
nordöstlichen Rechnungen die
Temperaturen sinken auf 7 Grad an der
Nordseeküste und bis minus ein Grad auf
der Alpe und morgen bleibt es sehr kühl
am Alpenrand dort steigen die
Temperaturen nicht über fünf hinaus 16
Grad werden es in der Uckermark und
morgen zieht dieser kleine
Kaltlufttropfen dieser wolkenwirbel von
Bonn über Brüssel weiter bis zum
Ärmelkanal dahinter lockern die Wolken
zum Teil auf und so kann sich morgen
hier im nördlichen Brandenburg bis nach
Schleswig-Holstein besonders am
Nachmittag häufiger die Sonne zeigen bei
Ostwind sonst gibt's viele Regenschauer
zum Teil mit Schnee vermischt und auch
mal ein einzelnes Gewitter der Freitag
wird schon deutlich milder am Samstag
klettern die Temperaturen bis 22 Grad
und danach können Sie das eigentlich
vergessen guten Abend